problema 95 dice el salario semanal de
un agente de ventas es igual a un
salario fijo base creo que es bueno ir
apuntando esto el salario semanal es
igual a un salario fijo base más una
comisión que es directamente
proporcional a la cantidad de artículos
vendidos entonces vamos a ponerle que es
igual a este salario base más x por la
cantidad de artículos vendidos vale así
le voy a poner entonces nos preguntan si
se venden 50 artículos esta semana
entonces esta semana se venden 50
artículos artículos la pregunta es cuál
es el salario de esta semana para el
agente de ventas entonces queremos el
salario
salario de esta esta semana
muy bien entonces en el inciso 1 lo que
nos dice es que la semana pasada se
vendieron 45 artículos
entonces 45 artículos artículos la
semana pasada por supuesto que esto no
nos va a servir para responder lo que
queremos verdad porque nos está dando
información de los artículos que se
vendieron la semana pasada pero queremos
el salario de esta entonces el 1 no
sirve por sí mismo el 2 voy a poner el 1
otra vez no el 2 el 2 lo que nos dice es
que el salario de la semana pasada fue
405 entonces el salario
salario de la semana pasada pasada fue
405 405 ok me parece que bueno por
supuesto que estoy aquí tampoco es
información suficiente verdad saber el
salario de la semana pasada no nos dice
nada del salario de ésta porque se
pudieron haber vendido una distinta
cantidad de artículos pero me parece que
ni siquiera juntando la información de
las dos podemos responder observa lo que
nos dice lo que nos dicen estos dos
incisos es que 405 405 que es el salario
de la semana pasada es igual al salario
base más más 45 verdad más 45 por equis
vamos a ponerle así 40 y 45 x 45 x x es
lo que gana el agente de ventas por cada
artículo vendido de comisión pero de
aquí no podemos encontrar el valor de ve
ni el valor de x y queremos pues
encontrar este salario y el salario de
aquí el salario es igual a b b + x por a
pero sabemos que esta semana fue 50
entonces tenemos esto de aquí y de aquí
queremos determinar b más 50 x pero no
lo podemos hacer verdad aquí tenemos que
es hebe y x como variable aquí b y x
entonces sólo son dos ecuaciones con
tres variables y así no podemos
encontrar lo que nos piden ni siquiera
juntando la información de ambas
entonces la respuesta sería y vamos
ahora al problema 96 en el 96 nos dicen
que juan tiene una cita con el doctor en
cierto día entonces la pregunta es si la
cita fue en miércoles
en la cita la cita es el miércoles es en
miércoles miércoles ok
qué tipo de información nos podrían dar
pues saber la información uno dice que
exactamente 60 horas antes de la cita
era lunes entonces 60 horas
antes de la cita antes de la cita
la cita es lunes es lunes 60 horas
cuánto es haber 24 horas es un día 48 es
otro día entonces 60 es dos días y medio
vale entonces 60 horas es igual a dos y
medio días entonces en realidad no
podemos decir nada de si la cita fue en
miércoles o no por ejemplo no sé
imagínate que que no se fue en miércoles
y que fue el jueves vale que fue en
jueves
jueves a la una de la mañana 1 de la
mañana no puede sonar un poco raro pero
hoy pero es una posibilidad a lo mejor
la cita fue el jueves a la una a la una
de la mañana y que sucede que sucede 60
horas antes dos días y medio antes pues
un día antes es miércoles a la una de la
mañana otro día antes es martes a la una
de la mañana y mediodía antes es lunes
entonces 2 2.5 días antes es lunes a la
una de la tarde a la 1 pm vale entonces
la cita pudo haber sido en jueves o bien
pudo haber sido que la cita fuera el
miércoles miércoles no sé a las 6 de la
tarde
tarde verdad entonces dos días antes era
lunes a las 6 de la tarde y otro
mediodía antes era lunes lunes a las 6
de la mañana entonces aquí tenemos
ejemplos en los cuales dos días y medio
antes era lunes pero la cita pudo haber
sido jueves jueves o miércoles entonces
saber esto no es suficiente para
determinar si la cita es el miércoles
vale bueno como que el problema es este
mediodía verdad que estorba vamos a ver
qué otro tipo de información podemos
tener en el inciso 2 nos dice que la
cita
la cita fue fue entre la una entre la
una y las nueve
a las 9 y esto es pm sale tanto aquí
como acá 9 pm 9 pm pues vamos a ver qué
sucede aquí vamos a ver si funciona que
la cita hacia el miércoles si la cita es
el miércoles y fue a la 1 pm entonces
dos días y medio antes que es dos días
antes es lunes y mediodía antes del
lunes
lunes a la una de la madrugada
entonces si funciona verdad y qué sucede
con la cota superior sí sí la cita fue
el miércoles a las 9 pm dos días y medio
antes fue el lunes lunes a las 9 de la
mañana
nueve de la mañana entonces juntando
este con este si podemos responder y
claro el segundo por sí mismo no nos
dice nada porque solo nos dice la hora
entre las entre las horas entre las
cuales fue la cita esto no tiene nada
que ver con el día pero juntando lo con
el inciso 1 sí tenemos la información
que queremos verdad o sea regresando
unos dos días y medio a partir de la 1
pm pues sólo podemos caer el lunes si
empezamos en un miércoles vale entonces
aquí la respuesta sería si tenemos que
juntar ambas problemas noventa y siete
en el problema 97 amir este está corto
nos preguntan por el valor de 5x al
cuadrado más 4 x al cuadrado más 4 x más
4 x menos 1
ok entonces la información que nos dan
en el inciso 1 es que x x x + 2 x x 2
es igual a cero entonces prácticamente
nos están diciendo que x al cuadrado más
2 x es igual a 0 o bien que x al
cuadrado es igual a menos 2 x a ver si
esto lo podemos sustituir aquí arriba si
así fuera tendríamos que 5 x menos 12 x
bueno la expresión sería 5 x menos 2 x 4
x menos 1 esto es menos 10 x 4 x 6 x
menos 1 entonces no podemos saber cuánto
vale verdad cambiando los valores de x
podemos hacer que valga distintas cosas
de hecho creo que es menos menos 66 y
menos 6 x menos 1 pero igual no sabemos
entonces está por sí mismo por sí misma
no funciona y en el inciso 2 nos dicen
que x es igual a 0
x es igual a 0 ah pues esta es toda la
información que necesitamos simplemente
sustituimos x igual a 0 aquí arriba y
podemos conocer la expresión este se
cancela esto se cancela y nos da menos 1
pero no nos importa que sea menos 1 sino
únicamente que podemos encontrar el
valor entonces la respuesta sería b muy
bien ahora vamos al problema 98
problemas 98 en el problema 98 nos dice
que en una tienda de autos de autopartes
la marca x de de anticongelante se vende
por galón y la marca y se vende por
cuarto pero la marca es de aceite
entonces a ver vamos a apuntar eso
tenemos una cierta marca x de
anticongelante
con g delante que sabemos que se vende
por galón
galón galón y tenemos una marca de
aceite aceite que se vende por cuarta
por cuarta cuarta y estas unidades
inglesas son muy latosas bueno a mí no
me gustan mucho pero bueno vamos a
seguirle así vale entonces lo que nos
piden es cuánto cuesta
y cuánto cuesta
cuesta un galón de x un galón de equis y
una cuarta de y una cuarta de g pues
vamos a ponerle un precio a cada cosa
vamos a suponer que que cada galón de x
se llama a y que cada cuarta de ye se
llama be vale bueno vamos a ver qué
información nos dan en el inciso 1 nos
dicen que al comprar 6 galones de x y 10
cuartos de iu entonces se gastan 58
dólares ok entonces 6 veces a esto es
comprar 6 galones verdad este es el
precio de 6 galones más 10 veces ve 10
veces de 10 cuartos de aceite nos dicen
que es igual a 58 a 58 de aquí podemos
conocer cuánto es además ve eso es lo
que queremos verdad queremos ver cuánto
es
queremos comprar 1 y 1 pues no de aquí
no podemos conocer a ver si aquí fuera
66 b entonces pues pudiéramos factorizar
el 6 pasar dividiendo y encontrar el
valor de hamás b
pero no es el caso entonces ésta por sí
misma no sirve vamos a ver qué dice la
dos lados dice que el costo de cuatro
galones cuatro galones de anticongelante
con doce cuartas doce cuartas de aceite
es igual a 44 44 dólares otra vez está
por sí misma no nos dice cuánto está más
ve pero juntando las dos debemos
inmediatamente reconocer que se trata de
un sistema de dos variables con dos
ecuaciones y por lo tanto podemos
encontrar a podemos encontrar be idea y
encontrar a más p entonces la respuesta
sería c cada una de ellas por separado
es inútil pero juntando las dos podemos
obtener la respuesta